[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous je dis 30 novembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
tout de suite les titres de l'actualité
locale
une centaine de personnes rassemblées
cet après midi à vue en cours une
mobilisation se tenait devant la
direction départementale et des services
courrier colis de la poste manifestation
à l'appel de plusieurs syndicats pour
soutenir un salarié convoqué en conseil
de discipline
vous le connaissez sans doute sous
l'acronyme pacs le pacte civil de
solidarité est un contrat entre deux
personnes majeures conclu pour organiser
leur vie commune est désormais le pacs
peut se signer chez le notaire ou dans
votre mérite plus besoin d'aller au
tribunal
reportage à plaisir enfin le compte à
rebours à noël pour noël enclenchée
avant le début du mois de décembre avec
le début du mois de décembre c'est le
moment pour ressortir des cartons les
décorations une féerie à voir également
dans les rues de votre commune à
maurepas un concours d'illuminations a
été lancé -a suivre également dans ce
journal retour sur la tournée africaine
du président de la république
emmanuel macron ce sera avec nos invités
ils sont à de l'association des
ressortissants africains de saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est à suivre dans ce journal et je
vous le disais dans les titres près
d'une centaine de personnes était réunie
cet après midi devant la direction à
départementale de la poste à guyancourt
à l'appel de plusieurs syndicats lui
manifestaient contre la convocation d'un
salarié en conseil de discipline
ce membre de la cgt est accusé de prise
de parole sans autorisation de la
direction les précisions sur place de
nicolas kirillovitch et patrick jacques
de dixmude
pour eux c'est clair et il s'agit d'une
répression syndicale plusieurs dizaines
de personnes étaient réunies pour
soutenir vincent fournier un facteur de
vélizy membres de la cgt convoqué en
conseil de discipline pour
officiellement prise de parole sans
autorisation tous les jours on est sur
le terrain pour rencontrer les facteurs
du département
et c'est ce qui les dérange c'est
contester leur politique tenté
d'organiser les luttes avec les salariés
sur le terrain et ils nous reprochent
donc là uniquement des de prendre la
parole et de discuter avec nos collègues
pour la cgt cette convocation est une
manière d'étouffer toute contestation
contre la réorganisation des services au
sein de la poste la direction de son
côté n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer pour le
moment il y a deux semaines déjà une
manifestation était organisée devant le
tribunal de versailles en soutien à
plusieurs salariés de psa poissy accusé
alors de séquestration sur un chef
d'equipe on sait qu'aujourd'hui dans
l'enseignement social ya plein de gens
qui sont sous le coup de la répression
qui peut aller jusqu'à la justice enfin
ou même des emmerdements policiers donc
il ya besoin de la solidarité il ya
besoin de se serrer les coudes et puis
de se défendre nous mêmes de résister à
tout ça parce qu'on sait que au bout du
compte c'est une machine qui cherche à
faire taire qui cherchait à museler
toute forme de contestation
à l'heure où nous enregistrons ce
reportage l'éventuelle sanction n'est
pas encore connue selon nos informations
l'agent concerné risque une semaine de
mise à pied
petite mise à jour que l'on a appris
entre-temps la direction et les
représentants du personnel n'ont pas
trouvé d'accord ne sont pas parvenus à
un accord pour une sanction pour vincent
fournier maintenant c'est la direction
seuls qui a désormais la main pour cette
décision ils ont la direction de la
poste a un mois pour communiquer la
sanction définitive à vincent fournier
autre mobilisation dans les transports
la fédération cgt des cheminots de
trappes appel à la grève demain vendredi
contestations entre autres contre une
réorganisation des établissements de la
sncf et de la baisse des effectifs
des perturbations sont à prévoir sur les
lignes n ai eu du transilien prévoir 1
train sur 2 pour les deux axes passant
par saint quentin en yvelines pour
consulter les horaires à jour d'être à
rendez-vous sur le site internet du
transilien rubrique itinéraire avec moi
sur ce plat terrain à sur ce plateau un
invité qui margencel satyam bonsoir vous
êtes le président de
des places de l'association pardon à des
ressortissants africains de saint
quentin en yvelines
alors vous êtes venu sur ce plateau pour
parler avec nous de la tournée africaine
d'emmanuel macron c'est avec un autre
membre de l'association qui nous
rejoindra dans un instant sur ce plateau
on va tout d'abord parlé de votre
association c'est ses missions pourquoi
finalement promouvoir la culture
africaine à 50 en ruine c'est l'objectif
de cette association l'association
aurait été créé en 1992
c'est une génération d'avant donc c'est
donc nos pères nos oncles la cria qui
ont créé cette association sont au
départ c'était dans l'idée de se
connaître
et puis également de favoriser
l'intégration des ressortissants
africains sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui l'association heureusement
ce métamorphose puisque on ne parle plus
trop et d'intégration mais on va plutôt
se diriger sur des sujets comme la
culture mais à voir la culture
promouvoir le l'afrique d'une manière
générale pour ceux qui sont africains et
également pour ceux qui aiment l'afrique
au début c'était avant tout rassembler
la communauté africaine de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines maintenant la
faire connaître faire connaître sa
culture faire connaître voilà
faire des choses ensemble et du coup
vous parlez de d'activités culturelles
de quelle sorte justement quel type
d'activité
alors on en a fait on en a fait pas mal
sur saint quentin en presque presque 25
ans on avait commencé par le carnaval
africain d'accord sur saint quentin en
yvelines c'était au tout début et on
avait d'ailleurs eu téléphiles 78 qui
avait suivi ce ce festival
ensuite ça a été des des conférences des
exposés sur l'afld sur le thème de
l'afrique
aujourd'hui on est sur la journée du
bien vivre ensemble c'est chaque année
en depuis sept ans maintenant on reçoit
où tout un quartier
avec pour une journée sous le thème de
la musique africaine et un bon repas
ensemble ça se passe sur tout le
territoire de l'agglomération bien sûr
tout le saint quentin en yvelines
invités et puis non une coupe de
football
également pour nos jeunes athlètes voilà
et pourquoi elle vous tient à coeur
cette association pourquoi justement
promouvoir cette culture africaine ici à
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est un fil on nous a on ne l'a
transmise
c'est savez en afrique ça se transmet de
génération en génération donc cette
association espère la faire perdurer
et puis également la transmettre à nos
enfants puisque aujourd'hui on est dans
cette situation on est papa et donc on
se doit de faire des choses à nos
enfants plutôt que de laisser la rue
s'occuper de nos enfants c'est ça on
vous a transmis finalement cette passion
de transmettre maintenant c'est à votre
tour de le faire montrer montrer le côté
positif de l'afrique montrer les bonnes
choses qui se font et c'est une manière
également de lutter contre contre le
racisme contre contre pas mal de choses
montrez vos côtés de l'afrique je pense
et du coup là sur les prochains mois est
ce que il ya des actions qui sont prévus
sur le territoire de saint quentin
alors il y aura t'on encore bien sûr la
journée du bien vivre ensemble ça ce
sera ce sort
obligatoire jeu pour être franc
l'association un peu mal en ce moment à
fédérer je pense que c'est dû aussi à la
de l'inventer et puis peut-être moins
être sur les réseaux sociaux et puissent
se voir tout simplement voilà mais on a
on a des idées on souhaite mettre des
choses en place
il nous faut des personnes de bonne
volonté on en a quelques unes
on en cherche tant d'autres recherche de
bénévoles
c'est important c'est important et je
vous remercie d'ailleurs de nous inviter
pour passer ce message
on cherche toutes les bonnes personnes
de bonne volonté
encore une fois pour vous joindre
d'ailleurs il ya votre mail qui
s'affiche actuellement en bas de l'écran
voilà c'est le mail satyam encore une
fois
merci pour cette invitation et et on
aura encore des choses sur saint quentin
en yvelines c'est évident à découvrir
également j'ai vu sur le site de saint
quentin en yvelines ya des sessions de
des cours de danse africaine c'est ça
qui sont organisées alors il y a eu il
ya eu ça s'il ya aujourd'hui non c'est
malheureusement fut l'auteur et du coup
qu'est ce qu'on pouvait y degrés
vous savez que sur saint quentin en
yvelines ont un run a eu une soeur
puisqu'on est dans l'association se
considèrent comme des frères et soeurs
tout simplement mon âme soeur qui donne
des cours de danse également d'accord
quel type de quel type de danse du coup
ces danses africaines annonce de tous
les pays africains à l'art c'est la
musique africaine surtout surtout un peu
salsa également fort et feront alors du
coup et on le disait vous êtes en
recherche bien sûr perpétuelle de deux
bénévoles pour pour faire vivre cette
association
patrick et yom qui est membre de
l'association ne nous rejoint pas pour
le moment où il est il est à l'art
africain n patrie idée on devait parler
oui ensemble de politiques et je peux
vous questionnez également sur des
thématiques politiques
bien sûr cette visite en afrique
d'emmanuel macron un voyage qui est
s'est déroulée d'abord au burkina faso
ensuite on côte d'ivoire et s'est
conclue aujourd'hui au ghana alors le
temps fort bien sûr de ce voyage c'était
le discours des maillots de mâcon devant
les étudiants de l'université de
ouagadougou au burkina faso
sur la forme on a présenté ce discours
d' emmanuel macron avec un style
dépoussiérer finalement qui rompt avec
la tradition des anciens présidents
français ce que c'est également le
sentiment que vous avez lu mon livre ses
sentiments qu'on a eus parce que je
pense que
le présent est trop jeune il a voulu
essentiellement s'adresser à la jeunesse
africaine pour son voyage donc
oui dépoussiérer pourtant ça n'a pas été
un voyage également simple pour lui je
pense un il a quand même eu vu
l'opposition une opposition en afrique
sur pas mal de problèmes qui dieu
quotidien ce n'est certes il n'en est
pas responsable mais également des les
actions passées de la france en afrique
puisque depuis cinq ans la france est en
guerre en afrique et aujourd'hui nous
aide vraiment et ce voyage
justement de de c2c pro d'aidé du
discours ce voyage là mais mais on sait
se montrer patient car il ya une
polémique et qui a été créé pendant ce
voyage une blague d'emmanuel macron qui
est mal passée auprès du président
burkinabé roche kaboré il est parti
réparer la climatisation c'est ce qu'a
dit le chef de l'état français à propos
de son homologue au moment ils
quittaient la salle une humiliation un
incident diplomatique où c'est une
fausse polémique
c'est ce que l'afrique est ce que ça
règle le problème des africains oui
c'est vrai que ça n'a pas rapport à
l'électricité jeux de mémoire par
rapport un problème d'expérience à
l'étudiante
université président de son équipe et
c'était pas sont effectivement donc il a
bien répondu parce que on n'a pas à
attendre
de la france
de régler ses problèmes de la société
c'est à dire d'ailleurs que la france
n'avait pas de politique africaine c'est
à dire finalement ne n'avais pas à se
mêler de l'afrique mais bon on tutoie
pas un président de la république par
contre ça vous choquer surtout sur le
fond on va terminer là dessus des
annonces si on peut parler d' annonce
mais il a parlé de la reconnaissance des
crimes de la colonisation de la
déclassification aussi des documents sur
l'assassinât de thomas sankara
l'ancien dirigeant burkinabé ou qu'on
appelait le che guevara africain il a
parlé aussi des crimes perpétrés en
libye / / contre contre les africains
qu'avez vous envie de retenir de tout de
tout ces annonces si on peut parler d'
annonce mais voilà qu'avec avez vous
envie de refroidissement forcément la
libye forcément ces esclaves aujourd'hui
forcément oui ça parce que dit c'est
forcément ça qu'on va retenir rsa ce qui
choque le plus nous qui sommes ici
ces faits d'esclavagisme et en lice et
c'est ce qui choque le plus vous en tant
que qu'africain france de français
d'origine africaine jet ski vous agirez
on en revient un petit peu l'association
il faut qu'il y ait des voix qu'ils
puissent qu'ils puissent depuis se dire
qu'ils puissent en parler et et même
hurlé puisque aujourd'hui c'est devenu
que c'est inadmissible tout simplement
inadmissible bon patrick youmna n'a pas
réussi à nous rejoindre à temps et en
tous cas on a pu parler de toutes les
thématiques merci à bouilly satyam
d'avoir été avec notre single je le
rappelle président de l'association des
ressortissants africains de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et je rappelle
que vous êtes toujours à la recherche de
bénévoles et pour contacter
l'association pour avoir plus
d'informations vous pouvez contacter
donc cette association sur l'adresse
mail qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci à vous tous ses biens ces nouveaux
depuis le 1er novembre plus besoin
d'aller au tribunal pour signer un pacs
le pacte civil de solidarité se conclut
désormais chez le notaire ou en mairie
c'est une mesure de la loi de
modernisation de la justice du 21e
siècle les communes saint-quentinoise
ont déjà été sollicités et mélanie poker
a suivi la signature d'un pacs à plaisir
une petite signature pour une nouvelle
étape après quatre ans de vie commune
sigrid et pascal se sont pacsés cette
semaine à plaisir
depuis le 1er novembre les officiers
d'état civil peuvent enregistrer le
pacte civil de solidarité et d pour
aller à versailles était beaucoup trop
long et
et c'est vrai qu'on quand s'est passée
au 1er novembre à la mairie on a dit que
on allait attendre de cette date
c'est une démarche plus simple pour nous
une nouveauté qui semble intéresser les
plaisirs oies en seulement un mois 17
dossiers ont été déposés le délai actuel
dans cette commune une quinzaine de
jours les agents ont été formés via la
préfecture
et c'est rentré aussi dans le plan de
formation continue que nous avons la
ville de plaisir
donc nous avons formé pour l'instant
trois agents mais à terme tous les
agents d'administration générale seront
formés pour la signature du pacs homme
un dossier de pacs peut être pré remplie
sur le site internet service public.fr
il doit ensuite être déposé en mairie
cela a été notre fil rouge tout cette
semaine le dossier de la rédaction sur
le fait main dans les yvelines ces
artisans qui vous font découvrir leurs
créations et dernier volet ce soit
consacrée à élise t'installes 7 plaisir
oise est ébéniste depuis 16 ans un
métier transmis par son père rencontre
avec mélanie poquet on ne trouve pas une
planche tout fait comme ça dans le
commerce avant d'avoir eu obtenir une
planche
on sélectionne notre voie et on l'a
semble t on la colle et liste installe
est un peu comme obélix l'ébénisterie
elle est tombée dedans quand elle était
petite
à 39 ans est plaisir aux as travaille le
bois depuis 16 ans en guidant les cocos
j'ai grandi au milieu des moeurs
ddd dans l'atelier de mon papa j'avais
toujours voir si je pouvais pas donner
un petit coup de main donc les odeurs le
voit
mon papa était aussi antiquaires donc il
y avait toujours des meubles qui
rentrait qui repartaient qui était monté
et démonté
donc c'est vrai que c'était familier
après une formation d'aménagement
d'intérieur en belgique il y suit un crp
d'ébénisterie son activité principale la
commande de particuliers dans mon
ébénisterie outre la restauration de
mobilier jeu
réaliste des meubles sur mesure et je
réalise des créations aussi donc
des meubles que j'ai envie de dessiner
de réaliser ainsi que des objets
décoratifs en bois donc soit en tournage
sur bois soit pareil
les petits meubles petits objets le fait
de produire des choses à la main c'est
un gage de qualité
parce que enfin en tout cas chez moi
c'est pas à part des petites séries
c'est pas de la production de masse donc
moi j'ai à coeur de choisir de bien
choisir mon bois le veinage du bois les
assemblages la façon de le faire
duchesne de l'érable sycomore du
merisier eli s'installe se fournit
principalement dans les pays où les
forêts sont durablement gérées un savoir
faire qu'elle partagea son tour j'ai
forme actuellement un jeune homme qui
est avec moi pour la quatrième année et
je les accueille régulièrement des
stagiaires donc ils sont soit en école
de menuiserie soit en école
d'ébénisterie et puis aussi
ponctuellement des gens qui sont
éventuellement en reconversion
professionnelle dont qui s'interroge sur
le fait de travailler dans moi il y a 6
ans élise installe son atelier à plaisir
mobilier éléments de décoration ou
jouets pour enfants une activité qui n'a
pas fini de tourner sujet a signé
mélanie poquet aussi de nicolas d'andry
c'est lui que vous avez entendu sur ce
sujet
c'est dans presque 300 jours la
prochaine ryder cup se tient en
septembre 2018 au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
à l'occasion de l'événement qui opposera
les états unis à l'europe
l'agglomération lance un site internet
dédié
vous y trouverez toutes les animations
et informations concernant le golf sur
le territoire avec des mises à jour
régulières
elle a déjà débuté à saint quentin en
yvelines la 17e édition de la fête du
conte se déroule jusqu'au 10 décembre
c'est un voyage à travers à mille et une
histoires hier à la médiathèque jacques
brel de magny les hameaux
les spectateurs se sont envolés pour
l'espace camille lambert vous entraîne
la tête dans les étoiles
ce soir là quand le soleil s'est couché
quand la nuit est apparu
[Musique]
les animaux ont regardé dans le ciel ils
ont vu apparaître
c'est l'histoire de notre planète et de
l'univers qui nous entoure
comptines dessin et théâtre permette au
plus petit d'aborder l'espace avec
albert 112 j'aime bien piocher dans
d'autres techniques artistiquement
d'autres ressources artistiques comme le
cirque l'agent de la jonglerie l'origami
ni c'est un public que j'aime bien
j'apprécie ça fait maintenant près d'une
dizaine d'années que je raconte pour ce
public
ce qui me plaît tout y passe et ils ont
un côté spontané sont vraiment présent
il faut du coup être vraiment dans le
présent avec eux
[Musique]
c'est aussi tort qui pleut il est tout
et si les contes s'adressent beaucoup
aux enfants pas question d'oublier les
adultes c'est pour tous les âges c'est
ça qui est génial c'est ça qui me plaît
aussi dans star là c'est que le conte
traditionnel il ya déjà le contrat dit
s'adresse vraiment il ya toujours dans
les contes traditionnels différents
niveaux de lecture et des comptes qui
sont plus adaptés pour les enfants mais
à l'origine traditions morales s'était
pas spécialement pour les enfants
c'était à la veillée se raconter des
histoires il ya toujours niveaux
différents niveaux de lecture et c'est
ce que j'essaie de faire dans le sind en
mai spectacle quoi même pour les
tout-petits d'avoir des petits clins
d'oeil les petites choses qui font rire
aussi des adultes pas d'âge pour rêver
se laisser embarquer dans la fête du
conte de 50 ans en usine
jusqu'au 10 décembre les médiathèques du
réseau et les lieux partenaires vous
invitent à voyager
les fêtes de fin d'année arrivent et
pour la première fois la commune de
maurepas lance un concours de
décorations de noël occasion pour la
ville de basculer dans la féerie
certains maurepas siens vont profiter du
week-end pour installer leurs yeux de
leurs illuminations et nicolas dans
driss ils sont motivés pour gagner cette
première édition
stéphane foncé ses deux enfants
profitent d'une matinée dominicale
ensoleillée pour se lancer dans la
compétition
il commence à installer leurs
décorations de noël j'installe les
premières qui sont au fait qu'ils sont
déjà pré installée puisque je laisse les
vices à l'année et du coulage installe
la partie façon charlene est enneigée je
l'aide à par exemple à monter les
décorations sur le toit quand on fait
des décorations près du sapin ou des
choses comme ça on je l'aide à les
installer je l'aide à aller tester des
choses comme ça les décorations convainc
m j'adore parce que nous disons sera
toujours lui parce que moi j'adore les
décorations
c'est mon cas et après que je suis sûr
qu'on va gagner et pour tenter de
remporter le concours stéphane a
renforcé ses illuminations les
nouveautés un bonhomme de neige lumineux
et une guirlande pour napper le toit un
rituel annuel à c'est l'aspect fait
l'aspect festif et puis comme j'ai des
retours positifs de tout le voisinage
pour concernant ces décorations comme
quoi ça un enchantement bah voilà ça ça
me fait plaisir
un enchantement qui touche même les
adversaires directs de stéphane à
whitera redoutable d'habitude taux 10
ans on s'est un peu la guerre pour la
décoration de noël
sauf que cette année et je n'aurai pas
le temps d'en faire donc donc il sera
largement devant moi fait toujours des
belles décorations des belles
innovations c'est voilà ont tous les ans
les attend avec impatience et décoration
et lorsque le test lumière est effectuée
tout semble fonctionner la famille fonds
séparé pour le passage du jury prévue le
18 décembre prochain
petit retour en arrière samedi dernier
les anciens et actuels de déclic théâtre
était à la merise pour la troisième
édition du trap impro family et des
retrouvailles autour de la marque de
fabrique de l'association
l'improvisation
retour sur cette soirée
troisième réunion de famille pour déclic
théâtre sur scène on s'amuse mais on
n'oublie pas la saveur de
l'improvisation c'est une soirée festive
avant tout c'est une soirée de plaisir
avant tout c'est une soirée de spectacle
avant tout mais après comment on fait un
match d'improvisation il ya
nécessairement de la compétition et les
joueurs d'impro i
il aime bien c'est au jeu du qui mieux
mieux quelque part alors il ya des
règles à respecter mais en même temps si
on enlève le match à tout ça si on
enlève le l'ingrédient match en fait on
se retrouve avec quelque chose qui n'a
pas nécessairement de saveur
documation ça c'est tout à fait
une grande famille qui écrit son
histoire depuis 1993 le temps d'une
soirée anciens et actuels de la troupe
joue ensemble
douze d'entre eux ont répondu présent on
joue à la maison des cantons at à petit
c'est génial et on joue avec des gens
qui sont petits comme quand on était
petits qu'eux et compte jouer et du coup
on se dit bah ça aurait été marrant si
que moi quand j'avais été petit j'avais
joué avec des vieux et maintenant c'est
moi le vieux chais déclic théâtre on est
accueilli comme comme un frère comme un
enfant si on est plus jeune et on est on
est chouchouté on et dorlotés on nous
emmène
on nous aide on nous fait faire des
choses qu'on n'aurait jamais fait
sans cette structure un rendez vous
réussi depuis trois ans cette année
encore la merise a fait salle comble
tu as entendu on arrêter avec la troupe
la soir bonjour tournis et mahler de
grâce la fin de ce set 8 journal avant
de se quitter je vous rappelle cette
information vigilance demain dans les
transports la fédération cgt des
cheminots de trappes appel à la grève ce
vendredi contestation entre autres
contre une réorganisation des
établissements de la sncf et la baisse
des effectifs et des perturbations sont
à prévoir sur les lignes n ai eu du
transilien prévoir 1 train sur 2 pour
les deux axes passant par saint quentin
en yvelines et pour consulter les
horaires à jour et d'être un rendez vous
sur le site internet du transilien
rubrique itinéraire ce journal vous
pouvez bien sûr le retrouver comme
d'habitude en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
tablette tv 78 on se retrouve lundi pour
une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale demain vendredi à vous avez
rendez vous avec le 7-8 l'hebdo de
nicolas kirillovitch bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]